welcome to 3abn today Bible Q&A my name
is JD Quinn I'll be your host first I
just like to thank you for watching
3abn I hope that you know and if you
don't I'm speaking for 3abn we love you
we respect you and you're just our
family I want to introduce our special
family here that's going to be talking
today and they're going to be answering
questions and I admire everyone to take
a topic that y'all send in
and be able to put it down into three
minutes to me it's just absolutely
amazing we have Pastor James rafy James
is great to see you good to be here JD
glad to join you for a Bible Q&A on 3abn
today amen Pastor Johnny deny it's good
to see you my friend thank you it's a
blessing to be here and I want to thank
everyone for sending in their questions
we really appreciate it and it helps us
to uh continue digging into God's word
amen and to my right is my precious wife
Shelly hello Shelley Quinn hello JD
Quinn we just want to encourage you to
have a paper and a pen to take some
notes because we answer from the Bible
and give you a lot of scripture
amen as Shelley just said Johnny just
said that we get those questions from
you and it's very important that you
send them in and it's just from A to Z
we're getting questions in and I just
want to tell tell you inform you how you
can send those questions in if you like
to text our text is 618 228
3975 once again 618 228
3975 for those that like to email email
is Bible QA 3abn.org
like to use Instagram that's 3abn uncore
official Once Again 3abn uncore official
so with that we receive the questions
each person gets to pick the questions
that they want to answer then their
homework starts and I mean these are
Bible students I'm just so proud of them
next thing that we're going to do is
we're going to have a prayer and then
we're going to get go in through the
questions father as we come before you
in the name of Jesus thank you Lord for
this opportunity that we can go into
your word father that we can sit and
take what you've given us and I just ask
Lord that as we get the answers that we
put that into action and we help make a
positive difference in other people's
lives Lord we love you we thank you and
we give you all praise and glory in
Jesus name amen amen amen amen James
we're going to start with you most of
the questions are going to be answered
in three minutes or close and we each
have one this going to be 4 minutes each
but we're going to start with a three
minute question James and this is coming
from
Diane how do we keep the Sabbath holy I
know that we don't talk politics during
Sabbath hours but what else should we
not
do thank you Diane for this question you
know when it comes to keeping the
Sabbath uh we have two choices basically
number one we can focus on what we
should not do or number two we can focus
on what we should do now if we focus on
what we should not do the list could
become endless and a heavy burden of
legalism this is what happened to the
Jews especially in Christ today they
they had hundreds of laws to guard from
breaking the Sabbath and why did they
need all of these laws because they were
living under the old Covenant old
Covenant obedience instead of New
Covenant love their hearts were
unconverted like Nicodemus in John 3:3
Jesus said to Nicodemus was a Pharisee
of the Pharisees right verily I say unto
you except a man be born again he cannot
see the kingdom of God and that word see
doesn't mean go to heaven it means
discern or understand the kingdom of God
see the kingdom of God is All About A
Renewed heart it's all about being born
again and having different motives to
serve God so there's one thing we need
to focus on doing on the Sabbath and
that is connecting with God so that we
can have this new heart this conversion
experience and then the things that we
once hated will love and the things we
once love will hate we will want to
spend time with God when our hearts are
converted so when it comes to the
Sabbath connecting with God In Prayer
connecting with God in his word in
meditation in song In Worship in
Fellowship in nature in helping others
in visiting the sick and shuttin in
visiting the Elder elderly or in resting
from our everyday secular labor and
engaging in spiritual recharge or in
just plain resting period And if on the
Sabbath you have time to do all of these
things and there's still more hours left
in the day start from the beginning
again start all over again Isaiah 58
talks about the Sabbath in this way it
says is not this the fast that I have
chosen to loose the bands of wickedness
to undo heavy burdens to let the
oppressed Go free and maybe you're
oppressed and you need that freedom to
seek to break every yoke is it not to
deal thy bread to the hungry and when
you see the naked that you cover him and
hide not your face yourself from your
own flesh and draw out your soul to the
hungry satisfy The Afflicted and then
shall your light rise in obscurity and
your Darkness shall be as the noon day
if you turn away my your foot from the
Sabbath from doing your pleasure on my
holy day and call the Sabbath a delight
unto the Lord holy of the Lord honorable
and you will honor him not doing your
own ways nor finding your own pleasure
pleasure but you will delight yourself
in the Lord when we spend time with God
when we plug into Jesus when we
fellowship with Christ when we abide in
Jesus the Sabbath will become a blessing
to us and we will naturally tend not to
do our own thing but to go in the ways
of God to do what he desires for us to
do and and the Sabbath then will be a
blessing to us and through us we will
bless others that was Isaiah 58: 6-7 10
13 and 14 I hope this has been helpful
in in answering your question uh
thank you thank you excellent
Johnny where in the Bible does it
indicate that there will be no more
grace to be saved once the plagues begin
to fall and this is from Alice well
thank you Alice for that question and
there's not one particular verse that
states uh once the plagues start falling
then you have Grace or you don't have
Grace but we need to look at some things
in the Bible that give us an
understanding that there's a time when
the opportunity to repent and to be in
harmony with the Lord is is over there
there's no more opportunity and one of
the places we can go is to look at the
Wilderness tabernacle during the
Wilderness Tabernacle there was one time
a year when they had the day of
atonement and on the day of atonement it
says in Leviticus 16:16 the high priest
is making an atonement for the holy
place for the transgressions and for the
sins of the people that's Leviticus
16:16 I'm just um kind of shortening the
verse uh in Leviticus 23 it specifies
that on the day of atonement the people
were supposed to be outside the uh
Tabernacle and they were supposed to be
praying and afflicting their souls on
this particular day on the day of
atonement why because the high priest
was making an atonement in the most holy
place so during this time they they are
there afflicting their souls all the
sins they have committed have been uh
they have repented and they have offered
sacrifices for and they were
symbolically being removed from the most
holy Place likewise the Lord Jesus
Christ is in the most holy place in
heaven there on the anti-typical day of
atonement the day of at warant at one
moment and so there's a time like in the
wilderness Tabernacle after the high
priest is done he comes out and he
confesses the sins of the people upon
the escapegoat all the sacrifices have
been done for the sins of the people the
atoning sacrifices were done now the
Escape coat which is a representative of
Satan also called the Azazel is uh the
sins are confessed because Satan has
some participation in bringing
temptation to the people and he has some
responsibility for this as well so this
Escape cat is is taken out into the
Wilderness to a place uh uninhabited and
there that goat would die off on its own
so it is during the day of atonement
that and and before the day of atonement
the opportunity is given to confess and
repent likewise Jesus Christ is the is
in the um Most Holy place in heaven and
we have opportunity now to repent give
our hearts to the Lord remember God is
not willing that any should perish but
that all should come to repentance we
have the time of Grace now this is the
time of opportunity but when you go to
Revelation chap 22 and beginning in
verse 11 10 and he said unto me do not
see the words of the prophecy of this
book for the time is at hand verse 11 he
who is unjust let him be unjust still he
who is filthy let him be filthy still he
who is righteous let him be righteous
still he who is Holy let him be be holy
still so uh when Jesus steps out of the
most holy place these words are
pronounced so there's no more Grace no
more opportunity to be saved and why why
is there no more opportunity really
because as you as you as you understand
God is not willing that any should
perish now is the opportunity to preach
the gospel now is the opportunity for
people to repent and why is there no
more grace because no one else will
repent it is as the work has been done
opportunity has been presented everyone
has said no that would ever uh say no or
that would never say say yes and if you
would extend the time a million years
500 million years these people would not
repent so they uh so there's no more
need for Grace because they will not
repent and so there's not one particular
verse uh that's specifies that but we
have this promise right now 1 John
Chapter 2 vers one my little children
these things I write unto you so that
you may not sin and if anyone SS we have
an advocate with the father Jesus Christ
the righteous we have this opportunity
now let us take advantage of it amen
thank you Johnny Shelly your first
question can you please explain job 35
5-16 and this is from Rodney thank you
Rodney for that question when you see
job 35 this is elu he is continuing his
response to job eloh who was one of
job's miserable comforters who failed to
recognize that job was being tested not
punished and so he's correcting what he
thinks is Job's misunderstanding of
God's justice the interesting thing is
even though he says some harsh
statements in judgment in a judgmental
tone there's partial truths in it so
we'll go through it real quickly job 35
5-8 what elu is reminding job is that
God is Sovereign and above human Affairs
he begins and he says look to the
heavens and see and then he goes through
this and summarize rises in verse 8
saying to job your wickedness touches
and affects a man such as you are but
your righteousness is for yourself one
of the human race it cannot touch God in
other words who is above influence this
is true Isaiah 646 says that our
righteousness is filthy rags before him
we cannot earn merit with God it's
righteousness by faith only Isaiah 5589
God says my way are higher than your
ways my thoughts higher than your
thoughts in Isaiah 59:2 says our
iniquities separate us from God and
still they don't diminish God's
character so now elu continues in job
35:9 through2 and basically what he's
saying there is God doesn't answer vain
prideful cries verse 12 he says there
they cry out but does not answer because
of the pride of evil man surely God will
not listen to empty talk he's accusing
job of empty talk nor will the almighty
regard it you know what there's a truth
in that 2 Chronicles 7:14 says that God
hears the prayer of the humble and the
obedient Hebrews 11:6 lets us see that
without faith it's impossible to please
God so if if we don't have faith and
submission when we come to God then we
probably our prayers probably aren't
going to be answered job 35:14 elu
wrongly assumes that job is being
impatient and speaking in vain and he
says in verse 14 although you say you do
not see him he's taking up for God yet
Justice is before him you must wait for
him and then he goes on and says job
therefore job opens his mouth in vain he
multiplies words without knowledge
here's the point God's timing is sure
his Justice his timing is perfect his
Justice is pure and it's not always
immediate but we will ultimately see him
judge righteously we see that in
Revelation 20 and verse 12 Jesus tells
us in Matthew 12 we're accountable for
every word Every Idle Word that we speak
so we should be careful not to accuse
God unjustly in James 1 2-4 trials are
meant to lead us to a deeper trust in
God not complaints against God but in
the bottom line is Believers are going
to suffer in the great controversy it
takes Faith obedience and endurance and
God's justice will be in perfect time
amen amen very good
Shelly James can you explain Ephesians 6
verses
5-9 how does this correlate with with
the slavery in American history in the
Bible when it says to obey thy Master
what does this mean and this is Megan in
Virginia thank you Megan uh in Virginia
that is uh a good question Ephesians
chapter 6: 5-9 reads servants be
obedient to them that are your Masters
according to the flesh with fear and
trembling in singleness of heart as unto
Christ not with ey service or as men
Pleasers but Servants of Christ doing
the will of God from the heart with Good
Will doing Service as to the Lord not to
men knowing that what soever good thing
any man does the same shall he receive
of the Lord whether he be Bond or free
and ye Masters do the same thing unto
them forbearing threatening knowing that
your master also is in heaven neither is
there any respective persons with him
now the correlation between what Paul
was teaching in Ephesians and slavery in
American history and even slavery in
Roman history because that's the context
of Paul's ver of Paul's statements is
the difference between night and day
right Paul is actually basing his
inspired words on the biblical standards
set up to guard against the cruel and
inhumane treatment of people who found
themselves slaves of other men for
example Paul in his letter to filon
actually sends a runaway slave back to
his believing Master with specific
instructions for the master to forgive
him the wrong done and running away and
mistreating him and to treat this
runaway slave as he would treat the
Apostle Paul himself Paul calls this
runaway slave a beloved brother in him
and we find that in fiman 1 the only
chapter of fimon verses 15- 18 so what
Paul is saying only makes sense when we
recognize that the Bible taught that a
runaway slave should not be sent back to
their masters they should not be
oppressed if we find this uh instruction
in Deuteronomy 23:15 to16 Thou shalt not
deliver unto his Master the servant
which has escaped from his master unto
thee he shall dwell with thee even among
you in that place where he shall choose
in one of thy Gates where it he likes
best what he likes best Thou shalt not
oppress him so Paul then is not
returning the slave to his master as a
slave but as a brother in Christ and
that is the standard that is set both in
the Old Testament and in the New
Testament for anyone who finds
themselves enslaved do the their
conditions in life now we see these two
vastly different treatments of slaves
All Through the Bible for example God's
chosen people the Israelites were made
slaves in Egypt for hundreds of years
the Bible says the Egyptians made the
children of Israel to serve with rigor
that is with severity and bitterness and
they made their lives bitter with hard
bondage in mortar and in Brick and in
all manner of service in the field and
all their service wherein they made them
to serve was with bitterness right they
didn't pay them they didn't treat them
well now when God brought his children
out of bondage he told them to remember
this terrible experience as slaves in
Egypt and to treat any who were forced
into slavery among them with love with
respect with Grace with Justice in fact
any injury that befell a person enslaved
among the Israelites even so much as the
loss of a tooth would instantly cause
their release from slavery in Exodus
21:27 God told them if if he knocks out
the tooth of his slave male or female he
shall let that slave Go free because of
his tooth so we see slavery in the Bible
represents a vastly or we should say
slavery in the Bible represents two
vastly different ideals God's ideal and
man's ideal because you have slavery in
the Bible that is very negative and you
have slavery in the Bible that came
under the principles of heaven where you
treat people with equity and Justice and
goodness and love so man's ideal is
oppression man's ideal is control man's
ideal is cruelty man's ideal is
indifference but God's ideal is that
this person is in a difficult situation
treat him mercifully justly
compassionately lovingly until they get
out of their situation and of course
that situation didn't last more than
seven years and then they were set free
but if the slave wanted to stay with his
master they would be taken in as one of
the family so a completely different
mindset that Paul is dealing with when
he talks about biblical principles of
bondage versus the way the world in his
day and in our day uh view slavery I
hope that was helpful wow very good a
lot Johnny yes sir Genesis 64 mentions
the Son of God sons of God being from
cth lineage but who were the the nephin
who did Cain have a family with if there
were no women or daughters on the earth
except e Eve herself after all he did
depart from his original family can you
please explain this and this is Giovani
in New York who were the
Nephilim thank you very much uh it's
interesting thing when you look at
Genesis 6:4 I'll go ahead and read that
it says there there were giants on the
earth in those days and also afterward
when the sons of God came into the
daughters of men and they bore children
to them those were the Mighty Men Who
were of old men of renown so when you
look at this word people
wonder uh unfortunately it's widespread
people think that these Giants were
Angels or uh that the Angels saw the
women and that they were beautiful and
they decided to have children with them
this is a
misunderstanding uh we well know that if
you have people that uh if if people
that are tall married with other people
that are tall The Descendants are also
going to be tall but apparently during
this time uh there were people that were
taller than others and so they had these
in this
intermarriage of the sons of God which
were the Faithful Servants of the Lord
with the daughters of men which were the
wicked people uh you can see a
separation between Cain Cain decided
decided to leave the presence of the
Lord and they were away and so for a
while the sons of God and the daughters
of men that is the Cain descendants were
separate people but eventually as they
begin to uh know each other there was
intermarriage going on now when it says
Giants this word has been transliterated
it's really the word Nephilim which
people believe was a race of people uh
it's been a it's a transliteration so it
appears to be a transliteration which
were of Canaanite descendants who were
they these were just uh a race of people
you have you can go around the world and
you see people with characteristics as
you go to different nations you will see
characteristics of individuals and these
people uh when there was this
intermarriage and it is said that these
um Nephilim were people that were
violent type of people people that were
aggressive and so people that are
aggressive get more aggressive as they
are with each other and and so
unfortunately the people walk away with
the idea that uh these were Angels if it
was Angels why would they why would they
limit that type of thing for that time
wouldn't Angels be doing that still now
uh if that were the case but no that is
not the case it was not Angels if um if
you want to look I don't have time for
the other question here if you want to
look at places like for
example um Luke chter 3:
3738 the son of Methuselah the son of
Enoch the son of Jared the son of Mahalo
the son of Canan the son of Enos the son
of Seth the son of Adam the Son of God
so the faithful people are called the
Son of God the same thing is said to us
in John 1:2 but as many as received him
to them gave he power to become the sons
of God even to them that believe on his
name so I have to keep this there for
now because of limitation of time and it
might help for him to understand that
there were when Moses wrote the first 11
chapters of Genesis that covers
2,000 years of chronology and so there's
not a lot of detail that's right Shelley
your second question should we keep the
feast days and this is from Dolores in
South Carolina Dolores I'm so glad that
you asked this question the mosic
Covenant was a temporary law that God
layered over his Everlasting Covenant of
righteousness by faith and the Ten
Commandments were at the heart of that
law but here's the point the old
Covenant was civil social and ceremonial
laws that included annual feast days and
and these feast days forh these
prescribed Feast foreshadowed Jesus
Christ his death his life his death and
his ministry fulfill these for example
Passover 1 Corinthians 5:7 says Christ
is our Passover Lamb the unleavened
bread symbolized Christ sinless life
first fruits 1 Corinthians 15:20 Jesus
resurrection it says he's the first
fruits of those who have fallen asleep
or died Pentecost Acts chapter 2 the
outpouring of the Holy Spirit when he
sent the Holy Spirit the day of
atonement pointed to Christ High
Priestly Ministry in the Heavenly s uh
sanctuary as we see in Hebrews 11 but
these feast days these annual sabbaths
were distinct from the weekly Sabbath
and they included Commandments contained
in ordinances there were food and drink
offerings there were sacrifices
and these feast days are part of that
old Covenant that temporary Covenant
that was nailed to the C cross according
to Colossians 2:14 we know he's talking
about that because Paul goes on in
context in Colossians 216 and 17 he says
let no one judge you in food or drink or
regarding a festival or a new moon or
Sabbath little s this is the annual
sabbaths which are a shadow of things to
come come but the substance is Christ
Ephesians
2:15 Paul says that Christ abolished in
his flesh the enity the dividing wall
between Jew and Gentile saying the he
abolished the law of Commandments
contained in ordinances so Jesus removed
that dividing wall and made these two
one men Hebrews 10 says for the law and
it's speaking of the Moses sake law in
context the law having a shadow of the
good things to come and not the very
image of the things can never with the
same sacrifices that's how you know he's
talking about the Mosaic claw which they
offer continually year after year make
those perfect who approach Hebrews 8:13
says that in that Christ renewed The
Covenant and called it a New Covenant it
says he has made the first obsolete now
what is becoming obsolete is growing old
and ready to vanish away we know in Acts
chap 15 the apostles at the Jerusalem
Council determined and decided that
Gentiles did not need to keep the Mosaic
law they just were obligated they said
to abstain from idolatry sexual
immorality and consuming blood so if the
feast were still mandatory certainly the
apostles would have clarified that so
scripture concludes that these
ceremonial days the feast days of the
Mosaic Covenant were Shadows of Christ
Ministry and they were abolished at
Christ's death New Covenant Christians
are not obligated to keep them but I
want to say this and make it really
clear it's not wrong to commemorate
these holy days if you or they were holy
days but the feast day if you're doing
this as an act of personal spiritual
practice just as long as you don't
believe that they are
obligatory or necessary for
salvation and one more thing I want to
point out Hebrews chapter 8 and verse 10
we see that at the heart of the New
Covenant just as at the heart of the old
Covenant are the Eternal Ten
Commandments the eternal a moral law of
God Amen very well explained Shelly I
just want to just take a couple of
seconds here and uh remind us each again
how to get in touch with 3abn if you do
have questions uh if you want to text it
it's 618 228
3975 if you'd like to email Bible QA
3abn.org
3abn official appreciate yall love
you
James your third question and this is a
long question since a Biblical day
starts at sundown how could Christ
suffering begin on Thursday evening in
the garden as it is frequently
represented as the beginning of the
three days of
suffering would that not be observed in
biblical time as Friday already just as
Sabbath observance begins at sundown on
Friday evening this still leaves all day
Friday Sabbath and part of Sunday which
is three days of suffering and this is
from Gary uh in Oregon but he's asking
can you please explain Jesus three days
of
suffering great question Gary from
Oregon thank you for asking and yes you
are correct Thursday night for the world
today is actually Friday night
biblically speaking let's begin with
what Jesus says right three days and
three nights he's going to be three days
and three nights in the uh Earth just
like it was three days and three nights
in the in the belly of the fish so some
of us are looking for three
24hour periods right and the Bible uses
inclusive Reckoning which means that
part of a day is counted for a whole day
and we might touch on that a little bit
more later but I can send you a more
detailed study on that we don't have
time to cover the details on that right
now but apart from inclusive recog name
your questioning about the actual days
and nights is very important so let's
take a closer look at how how that works
the first night of the three nights is
Thursday when Jesus was arrested so this
is the night one and as you said
biblically it's Friday night and then
there's Friday the daytime of Friday so
you've got Friday night and Friday
that's one day remember we've got two
days to go and two nights to go then we
have Friday night which is the second
night or the Sabbath night which is
followed by the second day the Sabbath
so now we have two nights and two days
we Friday night and Friday we have uh
Saturday night and and Sabbath Saturday
and then the Sabbath is followed by
Sunday or Sabbath night which is really
biblically speaking is Sunday night
right so Sunday night and so then we
have our third night and then we have
Sunday night being followed by Sunday or
Sunday morning which gives us our third
day so that's how we get three days and
three nights it's actually starts with
the three nights and well I shouldn't
say starts with the three nights it
starts with the night and then goes to
the day the in the day so you have
Friday night Thursday Friday night
biblically speaking and then Friday then
you have Saturday night biblically
speaking and Sabbath and then you have
Sunday night biblically speaking and
Sunday the morning of Sunday that's how
we get our three days and nights or
three nights and days now the Bible uses
this inclusive Reckoning for these days
which means that they are not reckoned
as full 24-hour periods and obviously
they're not full 24-hour periods uh the
three days Friday Sabbath Sunday and the
three nights Friday night Saturday night
Sunday night or Sabbath night is part
especially when you come to the first
part and the last part is partial days
but they're still included as days the
three days and the three nights so
understanding that uh in the Bible a day
precede or excuse me a night precedes a
day we look at that from Genesis chapter
1 then if you want more a a more
detailed study on this topic because we
don't have enough time to cover what
inclusive means specifically how what it
looks like in the Bible but there are
many Bible verses that can help us to
understand this if you like a more
detailed study just email me james.
raferty 3abn.org or just email 3abn and
ask for the study from James Pastor rafy
on three days and three nights hope this
was helpful amen amen amen
Johnny this is another long one if
someone had sex reassignment and
identified as the opposite sex from
their birth subsequently
becomes converted and accepts Jesus as
Savior okay and then they die and when
they're resurrected which body would
they have would it be the one giv it
birth or the later one that's resigned
uh resigned to them this is from Janice
in Scotland what body are we resurrected
with thank you very much uh for that
question and I'm going to read from 1
Corinthians chapter 5 15:
51-54 um uh first of all I'd like to say
this everything that we do to ourselves
in this world whether we we take stuff
out or put stuff in uh it's going to be
changed let's go to First Corinthians
51:54 behold I tell you a mystery we
shall not all sleep but we shall all be
changed there's the change spoken of
here in a moment in the twinkling of an
eye at the last trumpet for the trumpet
will sound and the dead will be raised
Incorruptible and we shall be changed
for this corruptible that's the way we
are now must put on incorruption that's
the way we will become and this Mortal
must put on immortality so when this
corruptible has put on incorruption and
this Mortal has put on immortality then
shall be brought to pass the saying that
it is written death is swallowed up in
Victory so this change that is yet
future and it comes at the last trumpet
will bring us to a better condition than
we are now again if we have made any
change to to our bodies uh taking stuff
out or put stuff in whatever the case
may be this is going to be changed into
God's ideal for us so this um
reassignment or realignment as you may
call it it will be undone you will be as
you should be uh in Christ Jesus so this
is the the uh one of the places you can
go and we we we we read it that um I'm
trying to remember where that verse is
it says that eyes have not seen neither
have Corinthians chapter chapter one two
32 thank you uh eyes have not seen
neither have ears heard neither have
entered into the hearts of men the
things that God has prepared for us what
God has prepared for us is far better
than anything we could ever imagine or
think and so I encourage you to be
faithful to the Lord and we look forward
uh for God to undo you know some of us
uh because of illness uh sickness um you
know whether you had cancer diabetes all
of these things will be gone and the
Bible tells us in um Revelation chapter
21 that God will wipe all tears from our
eyes he will make all things new and I
praise the Lord for that amen prise God
Shelly your third question is God the
Father Son and Holy Spirit one being or
three and this is from Gina in Florida
Gina this is such a special question and
I hope you've got a pin because I'm
going to give you a whole lot of
scripture to go with this and we're just
barely touching on it the Bible teaches
that God is one Deuteronomy 6:4 here o
Israel the Lord your God the L Lord is
one Isaiah uh 44 and verse 6 God says I
am the first and I am the last and
besides me there is no God and in Mark
12:29 Jesus affirms saying the Lord Our
God the Lord is one but the godhead the
essence of the Divine being is revealed
in the personhood of the Father Son and
Holy SP Spirit who are all called God
this is going to make sense as we go
through but let's look just at a couple
on the Father John 6:27 it says God the
father has set his seal on him speaking
of Jesus 1 Corinthians 886 says for us
there is one God the Father okay then
the son John 1 verses 1-3 and verse 14
in the beginning was the word the word
was with God the Word was God and the
word became flesh so Colossians 2:9 it
says in him speaking of Christ in him
dwells all the fullness of the godhead
bodily in Hebrews 1 18 the father is now
speaking to his Covenant son the person
of Jesus Christ who says but to the son
he says this is the one in heaven
speaking to the one on earth your throne
oh God he says to the son your throne oh
God is forever and ever now the Holy
Spirit acts 5 3-4 we see that lying to
the holy spirit is said to be lying to
God 1 Corinthians 3:16 do you not know
that your body is the temple of God and
that the Holy Spirit dwells in you so
the father son and spirit are three
distinct people persons but they work as
one in Matthew 3:16-17 at Jesus baptism
we see the father speaks from Heaven
Jesus is baptized and then we see the
Holy Spirit to send like a dove Matthew
28:19 the Great Commission Jesus said to
baptize in the name of the father Son
and Holy Spirit second Corinthians 13
and verse 14 Paul says the grace of our
Lord Jesus Christ the love of God and
The Fellowship of the Holy Spirit be
with you always so we see this threein
one concept reflected in nature for
example time there's past present and
future those are all measurements and
distinct measurements yet they're all
time water there's ice liquid and Vapor
three different forms but the same
substance human nature mind body and
spirit but it's just one person
the formula for God is not father plus
son plus holy spirit that would equal
three it's one times one times one which
equals one the Father the Son and the
Holy Spirit work together for our
Salvation this demonstrates the unity
and the love of God Jesus was fully God
which means that his sacrifice is
sufficient for our sins the holy spirit
is fully God God works in you to Will
and to do his good pleasure Philippians
2:13 so to deny the Trinity distorts
God's nature and Plan of Salvation we
have to understand God is one God the
father son and holy spirit amen Shelly
great amen James your last question can
you please explain 1st Samuel
1614 does God send evil spirits to those
who refus to do his will and this is
from Benjamin and and
nambia thank you Benjamin great question
let's begin with a closer look at the
context of the text in question and that
is 1 Samuel 16 verse 14 but the spirit
of the Lord departed from Saul and an
evil spirit from the Lord troubled him
now in this context if we look at what's
taking place Saul is has departed from
the Lord and and he's been bothered by
evil spirits I'm going to just say to
you those evil spirits are the spirits
of the devil but it sounds like it's
coming from the Lord now if we read a
little bit further 1st Samuel 19:9 and10
we find that the evil spirit from the
Lord was upon Saul as he sat in his
house and with his javelin in his hand
and David played with played with his
hand so as Saul sits in his house
troubled by an evil spirit with a
javelin in his hand David's playing the
harp for Saul to try to ease his mind
and verse 10 says and Saul sought to
Smite David even to the wall with the
javelin but he slipped away that is
David Slipped Away out of Saul's
presence and he smot the javelin into
the wall and David fled and escaped that
night now think about this David is
Anointed of God God Is Watching Over
David protecting David and then we have
if and we think about this accordingly
we have the idea that God sent an evil
spirit to Saul and Saul was impressed to
kill David whom God is blessing and
protecting it would be a contradiction
so we've got to understand this a little
bit differently than what the text seems
to indicate and we get an answer in the
Book of Job job again is a book that can
really help us understand this whole
conflict between an evil spirit from the
Lord and what is really happening see in
Job 1 and2 God is seen as doing what he
actually allows the devil to do the
devil argues for job God sets bounds
around job God allows these bounds to be
removed but with restrictions the Devil
comes and and he decimates job's
children job's wealth job's health and
God is seen as the one who did it you
know one of the servants says in job
1:16 when all these calamities are
coming while he was yet speaking there
came another also and said the fire of
God is fallen from Heaven well that's
not the fire of God that is Satan you
know we call all of these insurance
companies have this phrase an act of God
it should be really an act of Satan
right so what we see here is that even
job speaks about God doing it Job
chapter 1 202 and job arose from his
mantle he shaved his head he fell down
upon the ground he worshiped and he said
naked I came out of my mother's womb and
naked I shall return thither the Lord
gives the Lord is taken away blessed be
the name of the Lord and all this job
sinned not nor charged God foolishly so
we see even job understanding this is
from the Lord now there's two reasons
for this number one there was a
misunderstanding the world the religious
world then and now still sees everything
as what God does he's Sovereign
everything that happens is is is his
doing the prayer that Christ taught us
to pray in Matthew chapter 6 tells us no
we need to be delivered from Evil and
not everything that's happening in this
world is happening according to heaven
and if God was doing everything why
would we pray to be delivered from Evil
because it's all God's will now the Book
of Job helps us to understand that an
evil spirit from God doesn't mean that
it's God doing it but rather the devil
being allowed to do it and God giving
him permission to do it um we see God as
doing it like in Job chapter 2 the Lord
said unto Satan have you considered my
servant job there's none like him in all
the Earth verse three a perfect man an
upright man a man that fears God and
isues Evil and he still s holds fast his
Integrity although you move me against
him to destroy him without cause but
obviously God wasn't the one that did it
Satan was but in the mind of job he
thinks that God did this and many times
we see God doing what he allows so
thankfully in the story of Job we have
the key that unlocks all these other
Bible verses and makes that make it seem
like what God is doing rather than
allowing and uh and we can ask uh god um
to overrule evil for good and that's uh
Romans chapter 8 ver 28 I wish we had
more time in this question but there's
more to it but there's a basic outline I
hope this is helpful that was very good
very very good praise God Johnny your
fourth question why did God create
Darkness night in creation even though
there was no sin Revelation says there
will be no more night night so that must
mean that heaven will be an endless day
why then did God create Darkness during
creation and this is from Jack why did
God create
night thank you Jack I think we shall go
to the scriptures uh in Genesis chapter
1 uh we have the scriptures that tell us
uh Genesis 1 it says in verse one then
God said let there be light and there
was light and God saw the light that it
it was good and God divided the light
from the darkness God called the light
day and darkness he called night so that
so the evening and the morning were the
first day and every single day it says
that the Lord saw that it was good but
here when you get to Genesis chapter 1
ver 31 it says then God saw everything
that he had made and indeed it was very
good so the evening and the morning were
the sixth day this is before sin enters
into the world so if God looked at
everything he had made which included
light and darkness there must be some
benefit for Humanity in God allowing
there to be a dark part of the day uh
even today as scientists look at the
benefits of sleeping in the dark there
are people that understand they
understand that during the night there's
a process going on they uh there's uh
cells that are developing uh and all
kinds of good things are happening as
we're sleeping as a matter of fact
melatonin is produced and other things
that are of benefit to us for for some
reason that is not fully revealed God
created night for us to have that part
of the day to enjoy uh
why it there's no explanation given but
if God looked at it and saw that it was
very good we should be happy with it and
so that's what uh we can see uh yes it
says in Revelation there be no night
there and some have said and looked at
this he says well there's not going to
be night because God is going to be
there and God is light so these are
things to consider and so we uh
encourage you to continue studying God's
word and it was had had sin not entered
we will still be have dark part of the
day and the light part of the day amen
amen very well Shelly your fourth
question can you please explain the
second coming I know Jesus feet will not
touch the Earth and he will take up the
Dead with with him as he uh comes and we
are alive will be with him but what
happens to the people on Earth after
this takes place is that when the
tribulation comes and that's from Mindy
and Iowa explain the second coming in
three minutes Mindy wonderful question
and let me just Begin by saying the
tribulation happens before the second
coming not after in Revelation 3:10
Christ promises to protect his faithful
Covenant people from the hour of trial
that's going to come upon the whole
earth his return is glorious literal
visible loud Global there is no secret
rapture we see Revelation 17 he's coming
with clouds and every eye will see him
Matthew 24:27 says as Lightning comes
from the East to the West so will the
coming of the son of man be he will
Circle The Globe like a flash of
lightning and every eye will see him at
the first resurrection this is the
Gathering of of the Saints 1
Thessalonians 4:16 And1 17 says he
returns with a shout of the Trump with
the shout of the Archangel and the
trumpet of God so the dead in Christ
rise first and then the living are
caught up together with them to meet him
in the air and you are right his feet do
not touch the Earth and it is so
important to know that because Satan
will triy to impersonate or will
impersonate Christ to try to deceive
people according to Matthew 24 in Jesus
own words in First Corinthians 15: 51-54
we find that we put on our corruptible
puts on incorruption Mortal mortality
puts on immortality and then we're taken
to heaven in Revelation 20: 4-9 we reign
with Christ for a thousand years
reviewing God's judgment so we
understand the Wicked to be specific to
your question are destroyed at his
coming by the brightness of his presence
or from the catastrophic events
surrounding his return in Revelation
6:14 and 17 through 17 it says that the
sky rolls up it recedes like a scroll
Every Mountain and island is moved by a
massive earthquake and probably the
tsunami iies that are caused by that 2
Thessalonians 2:8 says Christ consumes
the wicked by the breath of his mouth
and they're destroy destroyed by the
brightness of his coming Jeremiah 4:23
through 27 says that the Earth is empty
it's without form it's void it lays
desolate Revelation 21 through3 we know
that Satan is bound by circumstance
and he has no one to deceive them but at
the end of this Millennium there's a
second Resurrection when Christ comes
down with us and there's a final battle
with Satan in Revelation 20: 11-14 the
wicked are resurrected they face the
final Throne judgment and let me give
you this one final thing what happens is
revelation 20
11-14 the wicked fa uh
the the great white Throne judgment they
are thrown into the Lake of Fire they
experience the second death spoken of
four times in Revelation and they
utterly perish thank you Shel that was a
lot we're going to take a quick break
and then we'll be right back and then
we'll have some final thoughts
amen if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible
Q&A then tell your friends each Monday
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible QA 3abn.org
[Music]
live and then watch 3 reaban Bible Q&A
for answers from God's
word welcome back are there any final
thoughts guys and girls I just want to
add one thing after God executes his
Justice and destroys evil and those who
won't repent of evil Revelation 21 1-4
says he's going to create a new Heaven
and a new Earth where there's no more
sin or death or pain or sorrow and we
will live with God forever the Earth
will be restored to its original
Perfection like the Garden of Eden amen
Johnny well uh concerning who did Kain
Mary something to get you started
Genesis chapter 5 has the genealogy of
Adam and it says in Genesis 54 after he
begat Seth the days of Adam were 800
years that's a lot of years and it says
and he had Sons and Daughters as if to
say by the way Adam had sons and
daughters so who did came marry it had
to be a sister of his own and so
remember that uh Seth and I mean Cain
and Abel were already grown when they
were doing their sacrifices so he had to
marry his sister amen that makes sense
how about it James well thankfully just
going back to this story of Saul and
David thankfully the story of in the
story of Job we have a key that unlocks
all these Bible verses that make it seem
like God is doing what God actually is
allowing right so now we might ask the
question why does God even allow it and
we could go back to why did God even
allow sin and that is a question that
job eventually got his answers to
because we know that job knew his own
story and God is trying to help us to
understand this same story of the great
controversy amen amen well I just want
to thank you James Johnny Shelly I know
you put a lot of work on it and I want
to thank you our 3abn family for sharing
this time with us just know that we love
you and we thank you
[Music]